where are you right now i'm in a small
village called south queens ferry in
scotland just about 10 miles um west of
edinburgh wait so when did you move to
scotland the story is that okay
about eight nine years ago
i had um i was running a half marathon
on the isle of skye and it was beautiful
and you know uh and then i have these
things called oat cakes which are like
the rustic oat based version of a
communion wave wafer and i really like
the weather and so
five years passed i mean forward after
that i was having a really bad day at
work and my boss was gaslighting me and
i just kind of stared out the window and
then i went back to my desk and i booked
a one-way ticket three and a half years
ago
best decision i ever okay i'm gonna try
listen there's some things i need to
clear up with this story
so you were in scotland you went on a
marathon okay you realize
okay yeah i don't i don't want to lie
about that yeah no no
good wear good place to interrupt but uh
so so you run a half marathon in
scotland you realize it's really pretty
here then you eat an oat cake
uh you went to great lengths to describe
it as basically
55 communion wafers stuck together uh
you you washed that down i don't know
what that had to do with the story but
i'm guessing you liked the taste of the
oat cake then you go it's amazing it's
very scottish okay then you go
then you go back home
to uh the united states you're having a
bad day at work and suddenly you start
to think i don't need this [ __ ] i can go
someplace where i can eat communion
wafers all day
[Laughter]
yes uh i'm out of here and so then you
moved to scotland and you're living in
what is this town like is it a big town
is it a small town no i i don't know the
population it's a very small town it's
picturesque and beautiful
um it it has a um
very long and sordid history of burning
witches
um and a friend of mine actually lives
in a house um
where they burned the last witches in
south queens ferry it's a very
interesting story um why do they i just
feel like i should check are you a witch
yeah
i i wish
they're actually yeah i mean because
then i would like cast spells and have
more i just was for your safety i just
yeah you know i'm i'm curious about
something which is you said you have a
friend who lives in a house where they
burned the last witch they were burning
the witches inside the house
that just seems like that sounds like a
bad practice unless you're using the
witch for warmth you know throw another
one throw another witch on the fire it's
getting cold in here
i mean if they had been seasoned over
the summer it would have worked right
uh so she she lives in this three-story
house that's called the black castle
it's not a castle it's a three-story
house it's painted pitch black amongst
these beautiful idyllic little you know
pastel colored houses um it's like a 400
year old house so the owner and his
brother
um had this
uh reverend in the town that really
wanted to live in the black castle
before it's called the black castle and
so he basically maneuvered and had three
members of the owner's family um
convicted as witches and so oh what oh
it gets worse oh i said listen people do
this in new york all the time to get
that really good apartment yeah we've
all done it what we've all said wow that
that that apartment faces the park
that's fantastic uh and and an older
couple lives there and i've many times
gone to the super and said uh i accuse
them of witchcraft and then there you go
two short fires later i'm looking at the
park so well if to burn a witch the um
relative of the witch has to pay for the
firewood and it was so expensive back
then that that is what bankrupted the
family and let this evil reverend buy
their house okay because of all of this
they called it the black castle okay so
mimi um
first of all you're a pistol i'm just
gonna say it you are a pistol yeah you
really are you are uh a delightful uh
spice in in our day yeah and i thank you
for that